hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the Masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is the
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do
today's post is brought to you by
American Express candidate in their
Facebook page they have a new contest
that you can now vote on the results for
called take off with Americans press if
you check out their page you can vote on
which business owner should win the
contest now today I want to talk about a
young entrepreneur whose father didn't
believe he'd ever realized his goals he
set out to prove his father wrong
followed his passion for computers and
went on to build one of the largest
companies in the world this is a story
of Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak and
the top three lessons that you can learn
from his success Steve Wozniak is a
Polish American computer engineer and
programmer who co-founded Apple while in
school Wozniak tapped into his intense
passion for computers and started
designing computers on paper based on
the theories that he knew he told his
father that he would one day on his own
computer when his father said well Steve
they cost as much as a house Wozniak
applied we'll all live in an apartment
Wozniak didn't have friends growing up
he spent his time between his schoolwork
and his experiments things changed
however when he met Steve Jobs with jobs
the ability to convince people to give
them parts Wozniak went to work on
building the Apple one in 1976 Wozniak
and jobs started Apple together with the
goal of making computers a tool everyone
could use not just for big corporations
today Apple has over 100 billion dollars
in revenues and is one of the largest 50
companies in the world in two thousand
Wozniak was inducted into the national
inventors hall of fame and has received
honorary degrees from multiple
universities his plan was never to start
a company but rather to design computers
luckily for the world he decided to do
both
by staying committed to his dreams even
when his father doubted him Steve
Wozniak was able to build one of the
largest companies in the world to help
you scale up your company here are three
options you can learn from Steve Wozniak
auction item number one don't think
about the money you don't have I can't
tell you how many times I hear from
entrepreneurs that are not successful
because they don't have enough resources
to start if you look at the stories of
most famous entrepreneurs they didn't
have rich Investor's given them a huge
cash injection to launch their
businesses it's not about how much
resources you have it's about how
resourceful yard that will determine
your success as an entrepreneur Wozniak
felt that his best work came from not
having a lot of money to get started it
forced him to be creative make things
simpler and challenge conventional
thinking being short on funds forced
Wozniak to create over 50 designs for a
mini computer before he hit on the right
one that would work he saw it as a
personal challenge to create a computer
that could be sold to everyone like
radios and televisions were and he
wasn't about to let a lack of money hold
him back according to Wozniak when your
startup or an individual on your own you
don't have very much money so the fewer
parts you have to buy the better when
you design with very few parts
everything is so clean and orderly you
can understand it more deeply in your
head and that causes you to have fewer
bugs you live and sleep with every
little detail of the product Steve Jobs
and i started with literally no money no
cars the parts we use to create the
Apple one where purchased on 30 days
credit don't think about the money you
don't have rather what can you do with
what you do have
action item number two focus being an
entrepreneur requires a lot of
dedication and hard work you have a goal
for what you want your business to look
like and you need to focus your energies
and not get distracted until you get
there don't let the naysayers convince
you that you won't succeed and don't
give up too early before you've given
your business enough of a chance to let
momentum work in your favor Wozniak
needed to focus to be productive at
Apple he was stubborn with his ideas
confident that his designs would work
and force himself to keep going until he
solved the problem it cost him his
personal life in those early years but
he was a man on a mission and knew
exactly what he wanted so he went after
with all the energy he could muster
according to Wozniak the way I work
requires so much concentration getting
to know the problem well enough by
thinking thinking thinking thinking and
then you try every day to make it a
little better go through it again and
again cutting something off here or
there when I was doing this work well I
didn't have a wife or a girlfriend I
couldn't do anything else action item
number three partner up you can't do it
alone you either need a really good team
around you or you have to partner up
with someone else who complements your
weaknesses this seems especially true in
technology companies where it's rarely
one person who's the founder of the
business partnering up isn't easy it's
like getting married you have to really
know the person and make sure you're
picking someone you want to be with for
the long haul Wozniak knew he had a
unique set of skills that could
revolutionize the way people ran their
lives he realized though that he didn't
have the complete package that be needed
to launch the revolution he needed
someone who wasn't as inward and quiet
as he was he needed to partner with
someone who liked to sell and promote
and allow him to focus on the
engineering side of the business
partnering up with Steve Jobs proved to
be a perfect match for both of them
neither the two could have accomplished
the same level of success without each
other according to Wozniak I was shy he
was at word I created he sold I had the
incredible technology which was
important when you're starting up and
have very few employees Steve had this
big
I have to have a company and he had
foresight so remember don't think about
the money you don't have focus and
partner up to finish up this video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories about Steve Wozniak and some of
his best quotes Wozniak's volt is HP
calculator and Steve Jobs sold his
Volkswagen van raising thirteen hundred
dollars to fund the launch of Apple jobs
told Wozniak that even if they were not
successful they could at least tell the
grandkids that they had their own
company thank you for joining me for
another edition of modern masters if you
liked the video i want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
under the video stay tuned for the next
episode and make sure you go check out
the American Express Canada take off
with an American Express contest and
cast your vote today
you